l'annoncé a eu l'effet d'une bombe
lancée dans la course au vaccin contre
le coronavirus depuis le mois de février
sanofi n'a pas tardé à créer la
polémique avec cette déclaration
j'ai fait campagne en europe pour dire
que les états unis recevront les vaccins
en premier c'est comme ça parce qu'ils
ont investis pour essayer de protéger
leurs populations et redémarrer leurs
économies une attribution du est un
partenariat entre le laboratoire
français et l'autorité américaine de
recherche et de développement avancée
dans le domaine biomédical un organisme
qui dépend du ministère américain de la
santé et qui aurait versé une trentaine
de millions d'euros à sanofi pour
assurer la recherche d'un vaccin et
permettrait donc un accès prioritaire
aux états unis
des propos auxquels emmanuel macron
réagi rapidement la déclaration du
patron de sanofi a beaucoup ému le
président de la république car ce vaccin
doit être un bien public mondial et être
extrait des lois du marché et une
situation qui suscite un tollé au sein
de la classe politique française parce
que la santé est un bien commun à
soustraire au jeu du marché
aucune entreprise française ne doit
pouvoir jouer contre notre propre
souveraineté sanitaires sans s'exposer à
une nationalisation
sanofi annonce qu'en cas de découverte
d'un vaccin il l'offrira d'abord aux usa
scandale sanitaire social et économique
en disant sanofi a touché 1 milliards
5,2 c hier des millions de cice sa
recherche est subventionné par de
l'argent public français honteux il est
impensable qu'une entreprise qui a son
siège en france et qui bénéficient de
crédits d'impôt recherche des livres
un vaccin aux états unis avant nous vous
devez agir
sanofi pdg surpayés licenciement nuisant
à l'activité dividende record maintenant
absence de patriotisme ce laboratoire
symbolise ce que le capitalisme fait de
pires un vaccin doit profiter à toutes
et à tous sans négociation la commission
européenne a également averti que
l'accès au vaccin devraient être
universels une pression sur le groupe
qu'il le pousse à revenir sur sa
décision
tout en rappelant que la france et
l'europe devraient participer davantage
pour en tirer les bénéfices
j'ai appelé le pdg de sanofi france pour
lui demander des explications
il m'a dit que ce ne reflétait pas du
tout la politique de son laboratoire et
qu'il avait communiqués ce qu'il a
d'ailleurs fait pour bien expliquer que
toutes les populations qui doivent
bénéficier du vaccin bénéficieront du
vaccin
une rencontre est d'ores et déjà prévue
en début de semaine prochaine entre
l'elysée et les dirigeants de sanofi